hear that that is the sound of Hearts
breaking all around the world she's
becoming a royal rock star Harry and
Megan on Netflix the couple's telling of
their side of the story has taken the
World by storm Harry and Megan's new
documentary currently the number one
show on Netflix with 28 million
households tuning in to part one alone
it is the most watched documentary in
Netflix history public commentary from
the experts to the average Joe
overflowing on social media the series
trending for days on Twitter The Duchess
of Sussex has Unleashed on Buckingham
Palace and the British press having a
field day love them or hate them the
numbers and public engagement show there
is something about this couple that is
magnetizing but what someone who's
marrying it who should be supporting a
supporting Act is then stealing the
Limelight Royal expert afia Hagin says
it is what Harry and Megan represented
that as so many people invested in their
story The missed opportunity to
modernize the royal family something she
points out hairy underlined in the dark
as a biracial woman who looks like so
many people across the Commonwealth the
royal family are supposed to represent
but it was a missed opportunity that she
wasn't allowed to go out and do that
good work in Toronto the connection to
the couple runs deeper the documentary
also highlights Megan's time living in
Toronto for several years while filming
the TV series Suits when she stepped out
in public with Prince Harry for the
first time here in the city back in 2017
at the Invictus games and also her
criticism of how police failed to
protect her when Paparazzi was staking
out her Toronto home and neighborhood
it's cool that you know she lived in
this area and now it's a historical spot
back at her old Toronto haunts her
neighbors remember and sympathize when
Harry was here there would be a big
black SUV parked here with two big Burly
guys sitting in the front literally
people were skulking around in her alley
when you don't know somebody personally
it's very easy to be unfair to them I
think Tucson degree you can always be
empathetic to somebody who's in the uh
you know firing line of the public eye
Kayla McLean Global News